good evening and welcome to this
overview on scrutiny committee held on
the
24th of January I know my name is
councilor Helm and I'm chairman of this
committee
members we are streaming this meeting
live as well as recording and by being
present in the meeting you are giving
your consent to being recorded during
each item please put your hand up and
inclindicate you wish to speak I will
then invite you to at the appropriate
time please know that the YouTube live
stream sound recording is dependent on
the correct use of the microphone
therefore can I please ask you when
invited to speak
you remember to turn on your microphone
and turn it off when you're finished
please reference a page or paragraph
number when referring to the agenda
papers and keep your contributions as
clear and concise as possible
minutes of the last meeting on pages
five to eight oh apologies for absence
sorry I'm jumping the gun any apologies
for absence German apology
[Music]
thank you very much for that I'll go to
where I was going to go
missing the last meeting Pages five to
eight
are you all agree with that
can I propose her in a second to please
and Bill
Carly May sorry
all in favor
I can't because I wasn't there
right disclosures of interest to
disclose the existence and nature of any
disclosable peculiar interests other
vegetable interests and non-regible
interests relating to items of business
on the agenda having regard to paragraph
9 and appendix B of the code of conduct
for members members are also reminded
that they are also required to disclose
any such interests as soon as they
become aware should the need arise
through the meeting
public participation have we got any
Stuart
no public tasks to
come on
right we move on now to the review of
scrutiny work plan item number six
planning decision making Pages 9 to 22.
to consider the report of the overviews
group new working group copy and close
get to the page was it yeah
tonight
if you go to page nine page nine sorry
members I'm a bit slow I'm not used to
working with computers like this
I've got to 10.
yeah one more
got to page nine okay there we are
to present the committee working group
further reports together with
recommendation course of action for the
committee to the consider or scrutinize
in further detail I should have resent
that the committee considers the interim
response and recommendations of the
working group for report back to council
or reference to another committee as
appropriate or defining the scope for
actually scrutineering and engaging the
working group if any further work is
felt to be required
some of the issues there's this
scrutineering work plan item derived
from a motion a mold a motion by
councilor Fluker which was referred to
council by this Mitty an Associated
reference from Council in July
2022 on planning decision makings was
added to the work plan
at the meeting for the last meeting of
the committee in October an outline
response
from the obvious group working group was
received and the committee accepted the
working group's initial findings
conclusions and asked for this to be
worked up in Greater detail by the
working group for interim consideration
by the overview of scrutiny Committee in
December 22 it was felt that the
committee would then be in a better
position to assess how near it was to
being able to conclude making a response
and any recommendation either to council
or to the Revenant committees
with the aim of a final report to the
meeting of the committee in February or
March 2023
members of the committee were updated as
to the ongoing deliberations of the
working group
With a View to a meeting being held in
January 2023 to tie in with Target dates
set by committee for the response to
another working plan
ah Stuart do you want to report carry on
presenting the report then
well chairman you've made a good start
there
feel free to carry on
um yes chairman um as the report
initially states there this is the
second time this matter has been
reported back to this committee uh this
time in more detail than previously
um to pick up the points raised by
members of the committee on the last
occasion and
in 3.3 of the covering report
um the bullet points there
summarize the main conclusions of the
working group to date
uh on some initiatives things uh Way
Forward outcomes that could be
recommended back to council or the
relevant committee
um to pick up and and run with
um
I think it's worth
just emphasizing that the last of those
bullet points which says a new protocol
on planning decision making is referred
to in the appendix
um report
as almost The Logical conclusion of all
these of all these thoughts
um
because at the moment
um the council within its Constitution
and Associated documentation has got a
variety of
documents and reference points that have
a bearing on
decision making in particular planning
decision making and The Logical
conclusion would be with anything else
arising from this examination now to try
and pull those together
into a single planning decision-making
protocol document that could be adopted
afresh by the council for inclusion in
the Constitution it would get give it
added focus and added weight so I just
make that point in passing but um
subject to that I think it's for the
committee now to sort of wend its way
through the various conclusions and see
how it feels whether there is enough
there or whether it needs to send
anything back to the working group to do
more that's the essence of the
recommendation chairman
members
Carly May cancel the bay yeah thank you
Mr chairman
um this quite interesting isn't it
Protocols are all very well
policies are all very good
but only if you follow them
um and clearly
um having looked at the papers we didn't
follow our own protocols
um so why are we writing more
to then not follow them either
why was some of these protocols not
flagged up to members by legal planning
or governance
so we have failures elsewhere not just
at the front line which we are um and I
think that also needs looking at
it's all very well having you know
um lots of people and lots of Bits of
Paper and lots of policies and lots of
documents but they're only as good as
those which we follow
you like comment on that just one one
chairman I think the essence of what's
coming out
this exercise and what I've just
mentioned it would be a strengthening of
whatever you had there before which was
perhaps more guidance
um wherever it was held about taking the
idea of this constitutional Break
um to review
um
uh decisions or potential decisions
following a move to overturn an
officer's recommendation that would be
come more hardened in the form of a rule
it would be in the Constitution it would
be something more set hard and fast for
a committee to follow
in that circumstance
so I'm suggesting to the committee this
would be a significant strengthening in
the hardening of your existing guidance
into more firmer rules and procedures in
certain circumstances Council amazed uh
yeah thank you Mr chairman for allowing
me to come back um that sounds great can
we not have just words can we have some
diagrams so that it's easy to follow
um otherwise you're spending um lots of
time looking at lots of words that
sometimes don't make sense because
they're sometimes in the wrong order not
necessarily using the right verbs in the
right places and I'm fed up with it
I'm just fed up with it thank you
Mr Morgan
yeah thank you Mr chairman I just can't
help feeling that this would be a lot
easier to impose if we had a single
planning committee frankly but we
obviously are where we are
um I've looked at the report very well
and there's obviously a lot of work gone
into it can can perhaps the officer to
come back and just put a little bit more
flesh on the bones of exactly how this
constitutional intervention or break
would actually operate
okay suspensely
so I'm not clear there I just would
um ask that I wasn't clear whether
councilor May is part of the working
group whether you were referring to this
report or whether you're referring to
planning reports because what this
actually
um addresses is a number of different
issues and one of the things in there we
do look at is planning reports and how
they're presented and how they could be
presented in in a clearer fashion
um the other thing with that I would say
with regard to the work on the
Constitutional break is that there are
several different options within that so
obviously that would be for members to
debate what they felt appropriate or not
appropriate but it was one of the items
that we looked at in considering what
the possible you know this isn't trying
to say that there's any particular Way
Forward what we're looking at is what
all the possible options are to change
things for a better way to move forward
um and I you know I do agree that there
are lots of other things that may not be
followed and are not followed from time
time but I still think that a single
protocol for planning whatever that
contains would be a good way forward in
terms of perhaps trying to address some
of the issues that we were looking at
before obviously it's not going to
address them all because there are
things in there that in that item that
I've already taken issue with within
this committee such as a five-year
housing land Supply and whether or not
it's completely accurate so those think
those things are already being looked at
but what we were looking at here was
more looking at planning policy and
protocol going for and a protocol going
forward so just to clarify on that thank
you anybody else councilor Morley yes
thank you um when you say things as
regards planning and making it a little
bit clearer is that
because things are going to appeal a bit
more as well do you think are we trying
to Define
um
the rules of granting or not granting
permission
um well that sort of is it because you
know we're going against the officers
all the time is that what's encouraged
it would you say
I I think the answer is we were asked to
look at a specific case in points which
was a referral to the committee and so
obviously what we've drawn upon is not
absolutely everything else and not look
to other figure and datas but looking at
this particular case and some things
that might have made that situation
different I think that's very complex
but it was an opportunity to look at the
our planning the way our planning works
and our decision making process works
overall
um and that was what we were really
trying to drill down in and to provide a
report for the committee to consider on
whether or not there are recommendations
that come out of this that we would want
to make or not want to make to fall
Council okay
and the other trouble we have is
planning officers come from all over the
country they don't live in this area so
they're making decisions on something
they don't see only other than Google
and
and photographs that um
what I'm trying to say is that the
officers rely on their Juniors to go and
take pictures of the site
and they're remotely working from say
Cornwall or Devon yeah but when you've
lived in summer for 60 years you kind of
know you know everything that's where it
comes back to members decisions again
all over moved
thank you I think what we're looking at
here is
um and I understand the perception that
there are problems with other parts of
the system that have have or haven't
worked
um but what we're looking at here we can
only really look at what one one thing
at a time in a sense and what we're
trying to look at here is a way for us
to move forward to avoid some potential
football uh I'll say that again
to avoid some potential
um problems in the way
um that we make make planning decisions
um that's not to say that we're
saying here that members are always that
for an officer's arm or anything it's
not really looking at that it's and
actually if you when you read the report
through it does look at for example when
we go to appeal whether or not an
officer who disagrees with the decision
that members have made whether or not it
should be that that officer or a
different person who's representing the
case
um at the appeal so I think it it it
broaches quite a lot of things but the
idea is it's it's drawing together
looking at what we do and in one
protocol so that you know that's how we
address this particular issue
um and that's what we've come back with
I think translate Maze and then cancel
them all my only comment was is again
nobody actually highlighted this it was
it's very clear in in the motion that
was put
that this protocol exists and yet we
ignored it
and and to me it's you can write
whatever you like unless they're flagged
up to members and sometimes that's
continually and that is the job that we
require our officers to do for us
because we are not experts and we cannot
know everything about everything
Morgan Nix Pastor Morgan uh yes thank
you uh just really come back on on
cancer spency's point of guard to I read
with interest uh the question of
officers attending it at appeals in that
way and I also note that there was a
suggestion that obviously members
um should be considered for attending
these these appeals as well I mean I'm
obviously quite used to this are we
saying that members have not been doing
that up till now
no it seems to be surprising no some
haven't no well obviously and when
someone some wanted to go to the appeal
they were refused by the officers really
yeah well I find that extraordinary yeah
just on that point chairman I mean the
report brings forward the existing
planning appeals protocol which has been
in existence for several years now I
think it probably goes back to 2012
2013.
in the context of what you're
considering here it would be a good idea
to review and refresh that protocol
which would be built into this new
planning decision making because it's
all part of the not the actual decision
making but the fall out of the decision
making it's all relevant so
yeah thank you very much
um I'd I'd actually like to say that um
we throughout this report it seems to
just keep
um going towards a single planning
committee we have to acknowledge that
that motion failed and we are where we
are and the way I've read this is that
it's diluting or trying to dilute what
we're democratically elected to do you
run about delegation of final decision
to director in consultation which is
paragraph 13 to a chairperson and legal
officer it concerns me that this report
and and I'm going to say something an
admitted chairman that I didn't even
know about the uh Council amazes right
the planning an application peel
protocol nobody sent it to me and if you
expect members to read a two or three
hundred page Constitution and do their
committees and do a 400 page document
which we've got for SNR and read this
agenda that came out late because it
wasn't on the website where members
wanted to see it I think you're actually
asking a lot of members chairman and I
think we do need guidance from officers
and I think it needs to be all rounded
guidance guidance chairman we've had
planning training why wasn't we given
that that area of planning training why
didn't we know
you know and I I actually don't
understand what this is actually all
about and I don't see necessary at this
stage what recommendations you as
chairman or this committee can make that
is fair and balanced I mean there's
inaccuracies in here it does say when
you talk about appeals that um 2.9 years
land Supply which is constantly being
quoted on appeals at the moment and we
all seen the the recent appeals was an
inaccurate figure but all planning
inspectors are still quoting at when we
were told that figure was incorrect and
what's bothering me is that the mistakes
are being continually made and one
question is why why is that being
allowed to make bitter con you to
continue to be a maid chairman so thank
you for allowing me to speak I'm not in
enamored with this and I do apologize if
I'm being a negative ninny but I
actually sit like that's the way I see
it and thank you for allowing me to
speak right I've asked you to see if we
can make papers available in the members
room for you to go and look through the
protocols on that can that be done
yeah it's been so the other one yeah
yeah the existing planning of tools
protocol is in the Constitution it's
it's an Annex to the guidance on uh
dealing with and conduct of planning
matters
yeah Mr
actually Echo what council stop saying
um you know I've been a member since
2019. you've been a member since 20 20
21 22 2022 I didn't know about it I
think councilor stamp has been a member
for a lot longer than I have I didn't
know about this why was I'm sorry but
why are these these important
pieces of information it doesn't take
much for a member sorry an officer to
say to a member look at this reference
whatever it is reference it and we are
we are we are constantly
constantly
um having the wall pulled over our eyes
and again like Council stamp I am fed up
with it yep
um and and this has got to stop
well I've been a member for 12 years and
I don't know anything about this never
seen it
do you want I want to speak yeah
so I'm just going to say one of the
things in this report that we go over is
member training
which I think is important and I as a
new member because I've only been here
10 was it 10 months not even that
um I certainly would like to have
different training not only more
training but quite different trainings
what we had because I don't believe that
it's delivered in a way that most people
can absorb and certainly it wouldn't
pass any sort of Austin inspection
that's for sure so we do we do need to
we do need to re-examine training I
disagree slightly with cancer stamping
that this isn't I do agree that there
are Parts where this would take away
decision making from us but there are
also other things in this it's not just
about that and it's about which parts of
this we would want such as whether we're
talking about new reports member
training whether we're looking at
whether or not I don't particularly
support well I don't support a
delegation option but a deferment option
there could be circumstances where
deferment for further advice
within this protocol I I would agree
with so that's why I'm that that's what
we've put forward if you would if if my
thoughts on this are that perhaps it
should be something the working group
has this working group here has only
four people and it would be really
perhaps useful in my opinion and it's
something that I might put forward at a
future day as a request for scrutiny
scrutiny of how we do scrutiny because I
do think that it needs to be given more
importance and perhaps be a wider thing
but um where we go from here is
something I'm going to talk to Stuart
about now I mean if members are minded
that they want to kind of put this to
one side all together fair enough or but
is there something is there anything in
here that you think is positive that
should go forward as part of a new
protocol and do and if you don't and and
if you don't feel that there should be a
new single protocol you know I think
maybe suggestions as to what what we
could recommend and put forward would be
would be helpful thank you
go ahead it's like it's just really a
sort of question I've always operated on
the principle if it ain't broke don't
fix it and I'm just this seems to
operate on the basis that the planning
systematic currently operates is
completely broken I'm not entirely sure
that's true certainly not from my point
of view I mean obviously there are
issues that could be done with it
however one aspect of this that I do
think is important is the business on on
officer reports I have to say I don't
the standards of reports that come to it
is confusing it's not set out logically
in my view I could have considerable
Improvement so if there's one part of
this that I would fully endorse it's
that thank you and probably that's why
you need error committees
so the members can have their input at
that stage because without that you'll
have nine people deciding and yeah
that's it's not part of this discussion
so we've got to work go back and work
this over let's do it
it seems
only in the sense that or only in the
areas where
um the committee feels it needs
something definite um to concentrate on
certain things as opposed to others
um let's not get too hung up on the idea
of a separate protocol that was just a
conclusion that came out a logical
conclusion as I said that came out of
doing the work to date in the knowledge
that we've got various bits of guidance
and protocols scattered around the
Constitution then that's that's the very
nature of the council's Constitution how
it's grown up over the years if you were
to start again it would perhaps respect
it would be a lot more codified a little
bit more logical but this is one step
towards getting it more logical rather
than have bits and pieces scattered all
over the place it will draw it all
together in in one place
um plus the fact that
um this comes to the committee on the
back of these motions to offer some sort
of uh idea or reassurance back to
council that things can be done some
steps can be taken to help
um mitigate or reduce the prospects of
similar decisions occurring again and
um the added strength that a
constitutional break in whatever form
uh it it might end up in
um gives added strength to the actual
planning decision-making part more
strength than you've got now
with that in mind if we look at 3.3 on
page nine I guess we could take what
pieces we like out of the bullet points
there and put that forward in a proposal
as a recommendation to council so I I'm
just wondering I I personally well I
don't know every I don't know what
everybody else thinks but my thoughts
are that certainly at this stage
um the Constitutional intervention seems
to be something that needs more thought
and perhaps is better after the
elections that's all I'm going to say
because we'll have new members here in
May
um
the planning appeals protocol refresh
with strengthening of member involvement
I think maybe that is important to to go
forward because I think that of
appertains precisely to the question
that the motion that we were dealing
with so I think that's that's important
and
um member training seems to be um
something that I'm feeling in the room
is everybody's agreeing with
um officer reports and and to and to
perhaps do you are people opposed to
having a new protocol at this stage and
would rather leave that for for
something that we look at later
okay well that's fine so then can I
propose that we adopt the bullet points
that we spoke of there the um planning
appeals protocol refresh with
strengthening of member involvement
member training
um including the uh what we've got in
that paragraph there and and um officer
reports
um review of the format an introduction
of um technical uh presentations so can
I suggest that we recommend that to four
counts to put that forward as a proposal
has anybody got any thoughts on that
catch a step do you mind if I just thank
you chairman that member training what
if you read the full sentence you need
to be careful of what you're going to
recommend because it says improved
opportunity oh yes oh yeah yeah you
can't just
put forward what what it is because if
you look at the context of it yeah thank
you for allowing me to say that chairman
and can I say one more thing before the
members agree I know I can't vote but if
you look at page 15 number 11 this this
really bothers me and this bothers me
for a specific reason it says an advice
paper produced by Cornerstone barristers
in July 2020 looked in detail at best
practice for ensuring and planning
committees are advised of the potential
risks on appeal and costs award in a
court of appeal case involving it's not
about the costs now we know chairman
that at a recent District planning
committee hearing that I wasn't allowed
to speak on because I was in Warwick
members were distinctly advised based
about how they should or shouldn't vote
because of the costs that was going to
be to this Council now it's really
important that actual when you're going
to State a case or when it goes to
um the high court or whoever that we
need to be accurate in what we're
reporting and it bothers me that it it
now says while it is appropriate for
office officers to advise members of the
potential cost and reputational
implications of refusing permission this
should not be confused with or taken
into account as material considerations
in planning analysis or in the exercise
of planning judgment now I think we
really need to be careful how our
officers are saying that when it comes
to our district and our area planning
committees thank you for allowing me to
actually raise that because that bothers
me and it's highlighted in Orange thank
you was that Council amazing do you want
to say something uh no thank you I was
just agreeing with what cancer standard
was saying thank you Mr chairman
Council yeah
um on that member training
I think it ought to just say member
training improved opportunities for
bespoke and specialized training yeah
what do you need all that other tush for
you don't it was a technical term it was
so basically just stop after training
after the decision that last full
Council
our members happy with that to move back
to the working group and do that yeah I
was going to second that Mr Mr chairman
who proposed it me
all in favor yeah okay so chairman just
to clarify you're asking for these
matters to get these two matters to go
back to the working three three three
matters sorry
um to go back to the
um working group for more no it's for
proposal too
you can refer these so the mechanics of
it will be a separate report to council
arising from this which will obviously
concentrate on the things that members
have emphasized yes thank you thank you
right we'll move on to item
seven
it's gone again
I've had to lose my iPad because the
computer has stopped the mouse has got
lost I think it got caught in a trap
somewhere
a potential scrutiny work plan planning
enforcement do you want to leave their
orders and want to lead it or well
um just just to give it a little bit of
context chairman
um this has been before the committee
before
um mainly arising from two individual
member requests for scrutiny around uh
specific elements of the enforcement
process but nevertheless carrying with
it concerns about what's become known as
the historical backlog of cases which
form part of the enforcement program and
at the last meeting of the committee it
was requested that further information
on performance be sought together with
information around
uh where the enforcement program has
come from and where it's going to in the
context of the enforcement policy and
it's been before the working group and
um via that route this is the report
back to this committee with information
and you have officer support
um for the information contained there
chairman I've called it a I've called it
a potential scrutiny work plan item
because previously it was a a watching
brief item
um and therefore it members according to
the recommendation may be reassured with
what they're being told now or may
request further detail or actual
scrutiny of processors German
members
yes sorry
um yes I note that there is a the one of
the matters I recall from the last
meeting was the dissatisfaction we all
felt with the way that the enforcement
matters were published uh and trying to
make head or tail of those that great
screed of of uh information am I right
and saying or did I read write correctly
that the future that is going to be
revised and that we're going to have
that split down into it into Wards uh
it's a a list for each particular Ward
will be produced Gemini I think that
Assurance was given to the working group
at the time the officers were already
working on breaking that overall this
down yes Jim
and just further I should point out that
there is one of the parishes in my in my
particular ward has now raised a sort of
second level complaint uh with regards
to enforcement uh or lack of lack of
enforcement in in a matter in within its
uh purview and I just sort of really
want to say that this is a very
important issue I mean I know that the
officers involved are working very hard
but certainly the perception outside
certainly in my in my ward is that
enforcement is not working in modern
District Council
there you go
thank you Mr chairman
um a bit light on detail a bit light on
stats 22
what happened to 19 20 21 perhaps
something even before that where did the
big numbers come from initially
um question that's just a question
um
there are no timings on on the report at
all with regard to you know feeding a
um
an enforcement matter
how long is it before it gets to the
next stage how long are officers going
to be waiting and having it sitting in
their in tray none of that in there
um
how are they going to actually deal with
something when it's gone through all of
the processes and the application or the
the applicant rather has um
been refused planning permission and the
only option is a stop notice
um and yet we won't issue stock notices
why because there might be another
planning application coming forward yeah
and that could sit in the system again
for two years three years and another
appeal and so it goes on meanwhile
making Residence Life an absolute misery
again can't go on we need to be sending
a strong message
to everybody that's everybody from
us as individuals right the way through
to developers
um you know Joe blogs on the on the on
the street who wants to who thinks that
he can put up a
um a a
an extension without planning permission
because he thinks he's got permitted
development rights which we do have
um we are not sending out the right
message we are just ignoring it
there is no timings on any of this
there is always the excuse or we can't
do that or it could cost us a lot of
money well it'll cost us a lot of money
we'll have to dip into our reserves oh
dear
we need to be doing this we need to be I
totally 110 support all the work that
our enforcement officers do and we need
to give them the power
to do their job
and if it is if we need a stop notice if
we need a PCN if we need whatever then
that's what we should be doing and not
letting these things drag on and my view
is that a lot of these numbers you know
these big numbers we're still sitting at
574 across the district
is because they're sitting too long in
an intro
that's that must be so demoralizing for
for those those guys
you know and then they get into trouble
when they do try and do things
we we've got to do we've we've got to be
much more proactive
I agree with you there thank you
we have um
let me just so we have had these lists
gone for a long time we've got kovid
which is meant to have stopped some of
the work
we used to have it come to area planning
committees the enforcement to look at to
see what should be done but that hasn't
come lately the last one I did was in
here for Southeast when I was chairman
of southeast
and that's where we can sort some of
this out because we've got the local
base and watching just so you're aware
members cancer Spencer's Vice chairman
of the working group
that's why she does most of the speaking
because she's well aware of the uh
we'll work together we all work together
they might think I've got too much to
say no you're all right
Glenn someone says something to say
that's fine
are we back
hello
okay I'll go to councilor Beale again
please can you repeat what you were
saying before your calf
I can remember
we never have ever ever had enough staff
to actually really give it a good crack
at the enforcement I mean I've known
some items they're going for five seven
years
you know and he said oh well we haven't
got the staff to do it and the rest and
since the Kobe thing you haven't got the
staff going out on site to physically
know what the hell what they're making
to
say all right Heaven yeah that cancels
it out right basically
um the staff are not going out on site
so how can they make a judgment on
something they've never seen
they've never asked the ward members
if there's an issue yeah
but that's the main problem is they've
got they haven't got enough staff in
that department to actually do the job
right okay we've got Ann shortland who's
gonna say we have in a minute I think
and as said as a mentioned item six on
this appendix a officers acknowledge the
value of individual member involvement
on cases particularly to give a local
perspective okay
um and I totally agree with councilor
Mays we need it
itemized into wards
reason being when you get the page page
200 and you've still got another 184
pages to go this is right it wears a bit
thin
right okay and
just to say well a few things actually
um
that goes out to members into areas you
know the three areas yes
really committed so he has done that so
next time it goes out it should go out
in just the three portions so you just
go into your area and that make the list
smaller I'm not sure if we can do it
Awards I'm not sure if the it allows us
to do that I could speak to them about
it the other thing is I you know perhaps
I do agree with councilman Hayes it's
really difficult because there hasn't
been enough stuff and when it even if
you have a short period where there's no
one there the backlog quickly builds up
and you know these have been quite long
periods where there's nobody there I'm
not going to say there's enough staff
now because we don't we don't really
know that because we can only judge them
and get rid of that backflow
but one of the things I was thinking
that the working group could look at is
we've got a protocol but we don't
actually know if it works with the
processes that we have in place and are
going to put in place to be more
effective and it'd be quite a good idea
for members to have a look at that and
match it up and see if it is working and
the idea of having
a pro a process is you really should
process Math More processes so that you
know that when a case comes in you can
see it on a diagram
which um certain people are all things
really good someone's jumping up and
down here about your diagrams
[Laughter]
of Enforcement cases and does that
pathway then line up with your
enforcement protocol and that's when you
can start putting well in five days
we'll do base or in 10 days we're going
to do this but until you do that
exercise it it's almost impossible to
say how long things are going to take
because you can't see the pathway of
where your cases are going to go and how
you're going to deal with them
and the other thing might be a good idea
for the working group to look at is
how do
members have to be involved in your
decision making because you'd be there
forever you'll never do anything else
except looking Enforcement cases but
when cases get to the point of taking
the possibility of taking action how do
members then
become involved in that decision making
or what is appropriate because we don't
really have anything at the moment and
it might be a good item for discussion
and debate and an agreement so we can
all sign up to that but the other thing
I think would be really good is how do
we prioritize which cases we do first
who who is the top priority what is the
top priority and how do we work that out
because at the moment
from my observations of kind of during
enforcement and helping out if there
there isn't a lot of that and and what
happens is he who shouts the loudest
get their case done first and all the
other work doesn't then get done
so we need a clear process of how we are
going to deal initially indicated who
gets done first and it might be a really
good idea
I hope that's helpful yeah and in the
past area committees have met discuss
their Enforcement cases
I chaired the last one for Southeast in
this chamber and we haven't had one for
four years or something like that
they'll find it extremely useful
let's do it
really useful
at the moment with the back panel your
there's hundreds of them you know when
you're going to be there for hours and
hours and hours then I think maybe we
could devise a system for the future for
cases when we get rid of all that
horrible Matchbox
Stuart wanted to come in I think just to
clarify on the issue of area committees
getting involved in that I think we've
moved past the point of area committees
dealing with them in a formal sense
because all of enforcement powers are
delegated safe for injunctions and
extreme
um circumstances like that so area
committees don't ordinarily have any
decision-making powers in relation to
enforcement but what was offered
um was the ability for informal meetings
Gatherings of uh members on an area
basis which officers would then Supply
information to if that helped the
process but in the context of
um what's being suggested now for the
working group to look at in more detail
in particular member involvement that
can be looked at actually then councilor
Morgan then councilor stamp
okay so
um what I'm going to say is that um and
this is a little this is this is part of
one of my issues really with with how
we're doing scrutiny at the moment but
um when you look at this report if I
could just refer members and officers to
page 26 and if we go to
um point nine
um we start talking about
um Agricultural and conservation matters
are reviewed by subject matter experts
from the respective Fields who will
identify and race in the enforcement
team should remain remedial actions be
required to resolve any issues well
I I did speak about this on the
pre-agenda meeting
and um
the the truth is this doesn't actually
happen in reality so when we get a
report like this to committee what is
what is really important for scrutiny is
that we have a starting point where we
look at where we actually are and I
don't think this does say and I go back
to what councilor May said about the
figures but particularly that that
really stood out to me because for
example you know I know I know when I've
when I was on a actually in in public
session at a planning committee meeting
when I asked
um Mr Lee how we go about enforcing
environmental conditions and other
members in the room might remember it he
actually said to me we don't
so so to be told to be told that in one
context and I I do know for example
um in my own world where we've got um
you know where trees fail where there is
a condition that they had to survive for
five years etc etc and we've had cases
like that outstanding since 2019 on the
North haybridge Garden suburb and I'm
I'm looking at the list no one's ever
visited so I think when we come to her
report like this because we can't help
anybody move forward we can't make
sensible recommendations about staff
levels or how we how we you know how we
tackle this what protocols we have if
we're not starting from a really honest
Baseline and scrutiny is one place where
that really should be happening so I'm
not trying to be overly critical because
it's great that we've got the report but
I would just what we really need is a
picture I think I think you know I'm all
for it being referred back to the
working group and coming back to
committee again for more scrutiny but I
think we need a really clear picture of
where we're at and and What needs to
then we can look at ways forward and
what needs to happen next because I just
don't feel that we've got a really clear
picture and my fear is we'll kind of
look at this and they'll you know it'll
all just go round and round and round
where if we really want to change things
I think we've got to get down to that
Baseline of what what's actually
happening now and what we can do as
members to try to help make things
better going forward
yes thank you can I just pick up on Mr
Jennings sort of suggested implant for
area committees and Enforcement Officers
to meet perhaps on an informal basis
necessarily I fully take the point that
we the area so many Powers but we know I
assure you our inbox is a fool with uh
sort of complaints from from residents
to what's going on and we therefore we
are able to help prioritize one of the
most uh one of the key enforcement
issues in our particular areas and then
in fact moving on to that there is as I
said in a particular Parish a concern
and it concerns a situation where the
the the the the breach is because a
property is being occupied either over
the weekend or indeed uh occupied during
the night
of course enforce for some reason the
Enforcement Officers see my neighbor
well I don't know whether to actually
attend at a weekend or indeed uh after
you know after hours so I must wonder if
there could be some way of changing that
or that policy for them so that uh that
sort of relatively simple enforcement
action could be taken to that catch the
feel and then counts the stem
can I ask the officer how many people
are in enforcement
and how many people are in enforcement
um at the moment there's
um
I got it right
yeah there's four officers there's a 20
hours Brad men and I'm coaching and
supporting and helping with the
processes and signing off places and
trying to get the closed cases gone and
off the list
um but
two of I think two of them contractors
they're not they're not full-time that's
right yeah
the enforcement officers do consult them
on a regular basis because I've come
across it loads in the files as I'm
closing cases often reading cases so
they do they do consult them on a
regular basis no we don't we don't check
every condition on a planning
application there's just not the
resources to do to do that I mean I
would be honest about that we can't do
it but it could be something you could
talk about in the working group of how
you're going to do it it does have to be
funded though if you employ an officer
and the last Council we did have a
company
it's officer and that's all I did I just
checked all the conditions but the
funding from conditions checking you
know when you pass the condition
discharge that was transferred from
development management into enforcement
so that it did partly fund it but it's
something that you could consider and
look at now putting putting conditions
on if you're not going to enforce them
so you know at the end of the time and
um
our tree officer he works remotely
doesn't he
consultant
priority of how you deal with cases
which is
[Music]
called life and it will come out as a
top it always does listed buildings and
trees but you should be leaving the
office when you get a complaint or
getting out of your house or going and
having a look almost straight away
because they are top priority visit if
you don't catch them it's really
difficult to enforce yeah
these old cases or Frozen things like we
probably won't be able to do anything
about them
thank you anybody else I was Council
today I'm still I'm still uh breathing
here oh yeah um Carry On sorry sorry
cancer stamp yeah basically say you've
got four four members of staff
two are permanent
two are not
as in part time how many officers have
we got in the planning department
[Music]
oh well that's five points you lost is
there any uh the reason I'm asking is
because I think
the corporate leadership team need to
change the policies around planning so
that not only do they do the planning
applications
and there can't be that many
that if they've got any time or allocate
or time is allocated to looking at the
enforcements
in in their perspective areas I mean to
plan in deal with specific areas or do
they deal anywhere
we're going to get an answer Richard
Holmes please
assist the enforcement well yes they
will but I think you've also got a look
at the backdrop because we've had a
severe shortage of yourself and
development management too and have a
little bit on contractors so it really
is a little or no capacity in the
sentence as they stand at the moment to
actually do that kind of cross team
working and obviously we're grateful to
hand
um for actually assisting this from the
other side of the team in terms of the
the policy and strategies like the
course members also remember now we're
looking to reformat our teams into
certain one larger scene which will
actually strengthen that cross team
working and actually make sure we do try
to build the resilience but the honest
answer right up to now in the last two
years is we've struggled tremendously
with resources and we've had George's
everywhere in the same amount that has
had an impact in supporting again
activities such as important
I honestly think that members ought to
be speaking to the enforcement team a
lot more
um even if it's on like area committees
because then you're going to get the the
local knowledge coming through and then
also hopefully we can
as you said change the procedures so
that we give in and and the rest of the
colleagues a a cunning plan to say right
if it's this this gets done first this
gets done next
because I think they're probably
looking at they're probably overwhelmed
by literally the amount of items that
are there
and they've not got any sort of list of
prioritizations you know as in what's
more important than the others
so I think we need to help the officers
more decide on which which way we need
to go
but I definitely think officers and
members need to be getting together on
an area basis
to basically give you the local
knowledge and I really would like to see
the offices I mean
Is it feasible
for members to go out to have a look at
some enforcement things rather than the
officers go out
if we know what we're being told to do I
mean some of us
are not working at the minute but I
don't know I don't know if there's a
legal
thingy there is coming back on that
probably yeah and
I
it would be great
visits but I'd be so worried I'd be so
worried about it because at the end of
the day some of the people that we see
are very unpleasant and you know it just
would be safe I don't think to be honest
I have to say that their positive team
they're out on doing other site visits
for employment looking at all the
employment sites so they've done a few
site visits for us when they're drive by
enforcement it's about kind of using the
facilities within the council so people
are out and they can have a quick look
then yes that's that's that's great and
if men must have
if they know there's something in their
area and they drive past and they think
oh yeah well that's okay now or they're
continuing with that just by dropping a
line in the enforcement inbox that's all
good intelligence but I'd be really
nervous but I'll be really worried about
you if you started going out on-site
visits and talking to people I think
that would be I'd be worried
thank you for the councilor stamp can I
sorry councilor stamp have a go she's
been waiting along all right and I must
still read because you're going to talk
all right okay
right so yeah I I totally agree with
what Anne's saying I mean I do it when I
go out in my car I don't just go out for
one thing I'm multi-skill so like like
the officer was saying if they're in an
area looking at a planning application
and they just happen to have their
enforcement lists with them and they're
going past the door that would be a good
way of utilizing the time
so yeah that is definitely a good idea
and I can't think what else I was going
to say now that's fossilization creeping
in that's the stem finally yeah thank
you chairman
um you'll be pleased to know that Malden
District Council do have a plan in
enforcement policy and it was published
in December 2020 so we aren't working
illegally we do have policies we do have
processes so I want to assure members
and members of the public that we are
working legally and
um also chairman I think I don't know if
Mr Holmes can remember or misuse can
remember I'm sure that was it last year
or the year before when we agreed to
have an additional enforcement officer a
new what I call a tick list was given to
that committee to agree before that
officer was actually going to be putting
post I could be thinking I'm Dreaming it
but I'm sure it actually came so so
there is like a scoring thing on whether
you you think that's important so you
get five four three or whatever it is
I'm sure something like that came to
this council at some stage so if Mr
Holmes can have Clarity on that and can
I just confirm how many full time we've
got and if cats if um Miss shortland is
a contractor or a full-time employee
so how many full-timers do we have in
enforcement how many contractors do we
have
thank you I am
but
other unfair work full time I finished
four officers two contractors two
um blood counts I paid I my milk
contractor anymore I was when I first
came to the council but I actually
worked for Council now
um the ultimate person
only works 20 hours I don't I do know
that
the priority for this particular list
isn't isn't very good and could be
improved falsely and that's something
that I if you if you do decide you want
to help your enforcement working group
it would be a really good idea for the
group to have a look at that
having a tick list isn't isn't that
isn't that good there are better or
better ways of doing it and it's
something that we could talk about
and the important protocol yes there is
but I
I'm very keen for you to you just set
your map of the processes of how you're
going to take your case forward in its
life and then you map your protocol
around that that processes and I don't
think that's been done so it could be
improved
Paula so I was just going to say because
I do understand and why you might have
misunderstood what I said before with
regards to the arboricultural and
conservation matters yes you're right at
eight on page 26 you don't talk about
having a complete not having a
compliance officer
um but what I was actually talking about
and some of that is historic I
understand what you're saying they might
not be enforceable now but they were
where residents and others have actually
reported breaches of condition
environmental conditions on for example
the North haybridge Garden suburb where
trees died as soon as they were put in
and actually some of the screening
wasn't even ever planted and that from
looking at that list some of those
haven't been visited and there's the
information on the list is wrong I don't
know because I'm a relatively new member
from 2019 so I just wonder if some of
those are now going to be impossible to
um actually put in place we do need
because we still have residents come
forward and ask us are you ever going to
actually look at that so my thought was
should there be a process and are you
going through a process now where you're
taking off some of those and we're
letting residents know that they'll
never be enforceable because otherwise I
think the list just carries on and we're
not telling residents what the situation
is so any guidance you can give me on
that would just just be good thank you
chairman you didn't allow Mr Holmes to
answer my questions before you moved on
homes
the question was asked I think can you
repeat the question
yes I believe that that checklist did
exist but I think yeah
yeah German but I wanted to clarify to
make residents know that we do have
policies and procedures because it
sounded like we didn't so it's really
important and I'll tell you why a
resident messaged me and said are you
saying in that meeting this Council
doesn't have in policies and procedures
to do with enforcement so I think we
really need to be cautious about what
we're a legend or what we're saying that
this Council doesn't doesn't have thank
you Jim
check this and how we go about
prioritizing cases which I think we're
saying you know we could do better and I
think we will do better so but that
doesn't mean we don't have crosses and
procedures to follow
uh
councilor by yourself
um but just on that that point about
policy I did actually circulate that to
all ons members before the meeting
um it was quite close to the meeting
um to me it looks like we've come up
with a number of
different areas that we'd like looked at
the first the first one that Anne
highlighted was prioritization of cases
second Baseline study of some sort and
the pathways of of any enforcements
protocols for members and how we can or
cannot be involved with enforcement and
I think health and safety is a very very
important part of that and you're
absolutely right and some of the
individuals are not very pleasant
um after I was working question mark I
think we need to look at that uh closing
of cases as a specific
um and uh finally on my list I have
compliance officers uh or officer
um it's specifically in relation to our
new developments and making sure that
our new developments comply with what we
all sit around and
um decide but also on other new builds
and extensions
um going forward
um
it's not an exhaustive list obviously
but I think it's a start list
and I propose that that is the
recommendation that we put
um that the working group or the
enforcement working group whichever is
going to to look at this actually
um deals with
do I have anybody to second that yeah
thank you Mr Morgan
yes right okay
right are we finished with that item now
it could be all vote please yes all in
favor yes
thank you so all those points chairman
will go back to the working group for
further review and Report
yes sorry
can I use your papers because this is
done on strike
sorry members
computers go on strike
we're on item 10 now yeah
item 10 oh sorry swelling uh yeah thank
you Mr chairman before we move on
um I would like to ask why the item that
is item 10 has been moved from the
agenda the open Agenda to
um a PNC item could I have some clarity
on that one please
Channel Cheryl can you uh clear this up
because apparently the agenda went off
off the
internet then came back on Monday
um
okay
thank you Mr chairman I just wanted to
know the reason thank you so
we've missed out at nine
foreign
[Music]
my computer's gone on strike so I'm
looking through papers at the moment
yeah
chairman if I can help you you're under
the revised agenda you're at Agenda item
eight now which is any other items of
business at the gem of the committee
decides are urgent
and I think chairman you just wanted to
note oh that there's a committee to note
that
um the performance governance and audit
committee has decided to refer an issue
to this committee that is the
safeguarding of children and vulnerable
adults
um for review to ensure that to ensure
that the council is supporting this area
of work appropriately together with the
officers undertaking the actual work so
this will come this reference from pgo
will come formally on the agenda to the
next meeting of the committee but in
accordance with usual practice there's
no reason why a start can't be made on
information gathering around that topic
via the working group chat you've lost
it as well
right okay now we come to exclusion
no no exclusion of
Oak we have to resolve that under
section 100 A4 of the Local Government
Act 1972 the public be excluded from the
meeting for the following items of
business on the grounds that they
involved the likely disclosure of exempt
information is defined in paragraph two
two
uh part one of the schedule 12a to the
acts and this satisfies the public
interest test
I'll second that okay
not being yet
is this agreed agreed agreed
okay